hello everyone so today I'm going to
talk about Michael Cohan and self can
coordinate barrel functions for healthy
balls I label myself as a presenter
because I essentially did not be in this
proof besides writing down my hose idea
you know everyone know that Michael is
pretty lazy of writing down any proof so
that's my only contribution and this is
based on the joint work of sab and
Michael and in height of cross is by
alphabetic order from here to there so
and I was the one who took the picture
let's start sorry
let's start with some stories about
Michael so Michael and I born at the
same year but we didn't know each other
on your last summer when I was a
interact Microsoft offer us that's only
one way because he didn't know me but I
knew him I heard about his name for a
very long time
I remember the first time that I heard
about his name was probably when I was a
second-year graduate student and I was
trying to like look at what was the
strong student of my grade and I found
Michael at that time I couldn't believe
that Michael was the same year as me
because it is so many great work
why did essentially nothing yet so
basically I talked to my friend and he
was also conjecturing that Michael was
secretly some higher grade above me
because we saw that he skipped one year
during the undergrad but then I found
out that he was essentially the same
grade as me as well so I was really
really impressed by all his works and he
did a lot of things and I finally met
him at Microsoft during the last summer
and I was so impressed by his
intelligence I remember that the first
day I was talking to my girlfriend that
I might someone that I infinitely
smarter than me - she couldn't believe
me because I was helping her to do all
her homework than he should she was
thinking that I'm very smart but I was
telling her that's for real so yeah I
was very impressed by him and I'm going
to it's my great pleasure to present one
of his very clever ideas that we
collaborated during the summer so let's
start with the definition what is a self
Conchords function in that mushroom one
it's just a very simple function is
three times differentiable and also it
has to be complex and then we just need
this beard condition that the third
derivative so roots by
of the third derivative responded by two
times the second derivative to the power
three or two
so the constant tool in black is not
very important you come with an
accountant there it's not going to
change the definition by too much but
what is very important is the power
three old three over two and you might
wonder why do we have such a weird power
because this power give us some property
like scaling invariant for example you
you can put any constant a here and it
also satisfies the definition because
you will take the second derivative you
are going to get a square and you take
third derivative you organic going to
get a cube so the two term cancel out so
this is like the one invariant if
definition that we need so what does it
mean by self can coordinate you just
means that when the second derivative is
small then the change of the second
derivative is also very small for
example if the second derivative is
alpha at some point then the third
derivative is smaller or equal to alpha
to the three over two so this means that
within a distance of alpha to the minus
1/2 your derivative will not change too
much you will just change by a constant
so why is this property important this
means that your function is locally
quadratic it just means that within this
distance your function is lower bounded
by some quadratic function so Y is a
variable and if you look at the function
from a center ax is lower bounded by
some quadratic function and it's also
bounded by essentially the same
quadratic function but with constant
much more in front how to a quadratic
term so as we know this is essentially
saying the condition number of the
constant the function is like a constant
within this very nice region so
and as a side note we can also write it
in a slightly better shape of this
condition that the decencies we see in
the gradient to the minus 1/2 he just
say y minus x squared times the second
derivative is smaller or equal to one so
within this region the function is
locally quadratic that's what we want to
remember for ourself come for us sell
concordant function and what is a self
concordant functioning in high dimension
is also very simple if it's a function
from Rd to R itself Concordat if it's a
case that for every Center Ike's and
every direction we so one-dimensional
function look at the function of that
start from a central accent look at any
direction we and I look at this
one-dimensional function it will be self
Concordat for the previous what we
define as a one-dimensional can Hornet
function and remember the important
poverty of self can coordinate is
scaling environment so I don't need to
pre specify for example the normal phase
one or anything because if it's true for
a non zero is true for editing but I
think what I wrote here is actually knew
the Greek letter mu but in Mike Lee just
shows up as V so let's keep it and also
we can also define self conquer net
function or a site K which just means
that the cell can coordinate poverty
needed to be satisfied in this side K so
that's worry that's all we need and for
second coordinate function there is this
very important notion of detangle
employed which is the different
ellipsoid of self Konkani function i
have centered at x it's just all the Y
such that if I look at the local
quadratic term of Y minus ikz and
multiply by the - of f and x minus ax is
smaller or equal to one
so he say he leaves white Center the
attacks and the covariance of the
deployed is defined by the Hessian of
this function and why do we need that
remember you one dimension if the
function is one dimension what we got
here is the roof second derivative of f
times y minus x square and we already
know that this is a region where the
function is like a quadratic function so
in high dimension is also the same he
seemed so it's in this region of inside
the deccan ellipsoid region the function
is very well approximated by a quadratic
function so we can think of a self
Concord a function is just a function
that we see in every different ellipsoid
is like a quadratic function and the
only thing we need to remember here is
just if you have a very large hydrogen
so a function is very curved around some
point so in the DK it'd be fluid is
small so if a function is very curved
Laden is the the region that it looks
like a quadratic function is small so
that's a important property we need for
self can coordinate function and so the
question is why do we need such a
property of a function of course the
simple answer is quadratic functions are
very nice
they are very easy to optimize a self
concurrent function just means that the
function is locally quadratic so it's
locally very easy to optimize but why do
we need it to be locally easy to
optimize your ellipsoid instead of
hazard shape and this is because we have
the power 3 over 2 here if you have this
power we are going to cut Eclipse weight
and as I said this is only environment
up to scale in definition but is there
another definition and there is also
Michaels another contribution yeah very
recent work that he has rack a function
of a different property they called a
second-order robust which is a function
that the third derivative is actually
upper bounded by the second derivative
without any power
for this function the function FY is
actually locally quadratic inside the
interval so it's not adapting to the
second derivative of the function
anymore so it just like a quadratic
function in this week's region and if we
work out the high dimension region
version of this of course it's not going
to be scaling invariant so you need to
be a little bit careful about the
definition but if we work out you will
see that the function is locally
quadratic in our cube Y a box so it's a
unique normal smaller or equal to Y
instead of that you can live swipe and
myself here is that usually lives where
they're looking like a ball and they
have a nicer shape cube but it is not
always the case if your underlying
region is like well approximated by a
cube
you would rather consider this
definition instead of the celkon
coordinates and micro used this property
to get a faster much faster algorithm
for matrix scaling okay so this is what
I say you don't really need to have
these three or two but for this hog we
want to focus on it because usually for
most convex body he lives where this
better approximation of so what is a
self can coordinate barrier function
self can coordinate barrier function is
a special type of self concordant
function is defined over oxide k2r it's
not defined in the entire space Larry
Mura stefania set K and so first of all
this function f has to be self conquer
net so it satisfy the local quadratic
property and also it goes to infinity
where X go through the boundary of K so
basically you can think of it as a local
quadratic version of the indicator
function minus log of the indicator
function of K so this function will be
zero inside the connect site and and it
will go to infinity
outside the convex side
and theory so the cell can call a
barrier from J is just much more
smoother version than this indicator
function that has a huge jump so one
important property of the self
concurrent barrier function is the
deacon he leaves weight is always inside
the convex body because the second
corner function is going to be using it
outside this convex body but we know
inside deacon ellipsoid the function is
well approximated by a quadratic
function the quadratic function of
course is not going to go to infinity so
this implies that the Deacon lives why
this inside the convex body so the local
quadratic region of that self can
coordinate para is inside the body and
what we want were a good self can
coordinate barrier because self can
coordinate very aux have these
properties as a deacon ellipse why this
inside the body but all frost we want a
function to be as quadratic as possible
that just means that we want the deacon
he lives way to be as large as possible
so that's a measurement of the goonies
so if I can find the cell phone Hornet
function that the Deacon he lives way is
very large this means that is a very
quadratic very quadratic approximation
of the indicator function and so we want
to find a good self control name Tyra
and this goodness is measured by the so
called second coordinate parameter which
is smallest mu trust me that's mu knot
will be the Greek letter mu
such that for all X the second
derivative of I've is lower bounded by
our mu times the first derivative square
so as usual we have a square here
because we want the definition to be
scaling environment up to a linear
transformation so if this is true than
if you will plug in any constant there
then the definition is also true so the
question here is which is generally as
in optimization literature is if you are
given a comma excite K
so what is the smallest mule possible
for a self concordant function Jorge and
so the as I mentioned the intuition is
we want the Deacon live so it will be
large so why does this definition give
us a large deacon ellipsoid so so if we
consider this function so it just says a
second derivatives is lower bounded by
the first derivative so this implies
that if I look at the direction that is
correlated with so first the derivative
and I read the first derivative as a
function I trade the first derivative of
this function
afros I'm just looking at that mention
what if I trade the first derivative as
a single function then this is just say
on the first that you repped you of this
function is lower bounded by something
so the first derivative is going to
change very fast if my first derivative
is fast so if I go through going through
this direction which means that my first
derivative will be increasing so my
first idea reps you suppose originally
my first derivative is very large so
according to this formula the derivative
of the first derivative is also very
large so it's going to increase very
fast and then since it's going to
increase very fast as the next step is
going to be even larger and it will
going to be increase even further so the
functions blow up so it just means if
you work out the correct solution it
just means that the first derivative of
the point of Y is actually bounded by
this function so you can see originally
when y is x is going to be the first the
derivative of hike attacks but when Y
increase a little bit this Y is going to
shoot at this barrier and it will go to
infinity so what does I say is just the
sort of the derivative at Y will be
infinite if y minus x times the
derivative at X is bigger than nuke
so if the derivative is using it of
cross that I've cannot be inside the con
website so this y is actually going to
be outside the context I'd K I saw as
this condition is true and there is a
slightly subtlety but what you can
actually show is the derivative of F is
essentially the radius of the different
lives while center attacks
so pictorially you just show that the MU
times the different lives weight is
actually outside okay you're very strong
size is just if you look at a different
lips well then the function is locally
quadratic here but if you blow it up the
diameter by a factor mu and then the
whole different lives where it will be
outside K in the sense that if I look at
any opposite point going through the
center at least one of them will be
outside K so suppose you have a
symmetric high your youth you stand in
the convex body and you have a
symmetrical which means that you'll just
your eye will look symmetric at every
directions and your Deacon lives what it
will be also so mu times that you can
live so it will be in completely outside
K so this is a picture so this just
means that my different lips what is
very large in particular if mu is like
wow so my different lips why this I
essentially just recovered an entire
symmetric region of this convex body so
it's very quadratic
and so the main question is given a
comic site caihou smoke and the second
coordinate parameter mu b for any cell
can coordinate barrier function over the
call exit K and this is very important
for faster optimization for example the
interior points myself calendar have so
many more of can minimize a linear
function over K in the square root of MU
times not more absolutely Tricia so if
you intuitively since a function is
locally quadratic ya region that is
actually like one where mu smaller than
the original site and you know quadratic
function you can minimize it very easily
intuitively if you can convert a new
iteration but you can actually do faster
for square roots new iterations but
you'll know that this mu is very
important and so also like how what is
the worst case mule whatsapp shows is
that for any color exciting Rd there is
one plus little one D self can
coordinate para function so he
essentially D up to and also the leading
concert term is time yeah so of course
you know the worst case result but the
question is can we do better so we know
for Bower ellipse wait there is actually
a constants of Concord barrier function
which is just a log barrier function
it's a log of 1 minus how to normal
facts and so now you might wonder if my
convex body is essentially about it's
very close to about does it
automatically implies that I will have a
self concurrently function with very
small self concurrent parameter because
you know self con Cornett parameter is
measuring how well you can approximate
the function the barrier at the convex
site by ellipse way that you'll take
this ellipse where you'll blow it up so
you might wonder this one Osia are
equivalent so if I have a
from Hornet if I have a colorized body
that looks like a balls and my horny
parameter will also be small so what we
are going to look at is here's alfie Boe
in our d4p very closer to let's say peas
2.0 is your what so it's going to be
very close where our two ball which is
just a ball and what I'm going to show
is a micros contribution and he's he
actually finds a very smart proof that
the question what we conjectured to be
true is actually not true
yeah very strong science the science
that for any L people so the definition
is just what I mean I hope people here
is a union normal people so summation of
P norm is smaller or equal to what it's
like how he lives with in a sense that
not only if you look at look at our
people in the center is going to be a
leap like how you lives with because if
you look at our people in the center you
will get this expression it's when P is
very closer to and across this comment
will look like a gives way but the point
is at every point X if I look at any
point X inside our people if I look at
any point X inside the post or amiss at
access to be in sizable and I look at
look at the people you starting at this
point since there is a lives with that
center that acts in sizable and also if
you blow it up by just a slightly larger
factor so it's not inside the ball in
the strong sense that if you look at any
opposite point it will be out sizable so
it's not only the
the IOP ball is like a lips wide in the
center it's like a ball in the center it
also looks like an ellipse with at any
point so it locally just look highly
lips wait at any point so this is what
michael proof that during a summer and i
guess a proof is it's never written down
but it's already also already erased
from microsoft's blackboard so
but you know there is a proof actually
the proof is based on constructing a
fake barrier function that inspires a
upper bound for IOT regression and but
also what Michael show is that it's
although the LP ball looks like a ball
in a very strong sense but there is no
good self concordant parameter which
just means a very symmetric self can
coordinate barrier or our people must
have parameter Omega D so there is this
log D to the P over P minor tool but
when P is constant so like two point
zero zero one so the ball here will be
just a B to the zero point your one
closer to a to ellipsoid but the
sub-continent parameter is essentially
Omega D to the some poly log factor and
and also for non C matrix telcon
coordinate barrier the second corner
parameter must be D to the one third so
I'm going to define what is the
symmetric later but this was as I
mentioned this was an open problem for
like 20 years and microphone a very
simple proof that shows this lower bound
so what is a proof idea he's so there is
a one simple fact that for any cell can
coordinate function the self can corner
parameter mu is lower bounded by 1/2
times a suprem of X of I Phi X minus f 0
such as the pinworm of X is not smaller
little one but smaller if you do a half
so I look at a half region nodding in
terrible because if I look at the
interval of course FX is going to be
infinite but if I just took a slightly
concentrated Center so if the self
control parameter is actually lower
bounded by this one so of course become
whistle also generality assume F 0 is 0
because I think I have to accountant
doesn't change anything
and then we just need to
any eye from the axioms a 1/2 times our
people such as the value of life is very
large so I will just show the proof idea
for symmetric self concurrent barrier
function which is just a function so it
doesn't depend on the sine of X because
the definition of LP boy is the
summation of the absolute value of x I
to the power P smaller Q 1 it doesn't
depend on the sign of each X I so my
wanders an optimal barrier function also
may not depend on the sign of each X I
so I'm going to just show the proof
where the symmetric case and a symmetric
case is similar not similar is harder
but you can also get something out there
so what is Michaels idea Michaels idea
is just it's very simple so if you just
look at any ice in the LP ball and any
is such that X plus a is inside the
deccan ellipsoid Center attacks we know
that the function f is is locally
quadratic in this different lives with
this just means that f of X plus a plus
f of X minus a is bigger than to FX plus
some quadratic term and if F is only
convex you will not have this quadratic
term but I feel okole quadratic so you
also have this quadratic blow-up of this
function so it's very simple and we all
know that Deacon lives what is inside
the LP ball
this just means that Deacon lives by
this small is inside our V ball so it
cannot be too large so different lives
wide is very small then the property is
what we need is defined in small and -
is large so that's what I said is only
property that we need to remember so you
can is small and - is large so can I
show you show that this quadratic term
is bigger or equal to the two norm of a
square so the - is larger - identity in
some sense so pictorially is just if you
take only
such as X plus a is inside the deccan
lips wait then this one and average of
this two point must be bigger than this
super Empire normal face square so it's
a very simple poverty and you can
actually show it for every a by just
looking as a intersection here of X plus
B and you apply to X plus B and then you
use convexity you can show that this is
true actually for every day so for any a
this is true for a self concordant
better function over all people so it's
just very simple no it's just very
simple to get a lower bound of this type
so you're just for a symmetric I've if
you look at a point that has money ice
here and then you'll remove remove one a
you will replace it by zero by the
property we just showed and also because
the function is symmetric by the
property we just show you will get a a
square term here okay
so it's very simple and so this just
implied directly implies that if I put
all the A's height it will be bigger
than F 0 plus some D times a square I
just use this formula for D times
ok so what you need is the the final
point is inside the ball inside a half
the ball so you need D times a to the
power P is smaller who a half and then
you'll get a D times of a seed has a
square so this can be as large as it has
1 minus 2 or P if I just take a it will
be e to the 1 minus 1 or P ok so we just
proved the second cornet barrel it's
bigger than the e to the 1 minus 2r okey
but this is not really good because when
P is very large like new in it
you prove that the South corner
parameter is Omega D that's the optimal
thing but what we care is a case that
piece were closer to four piece we're
closer to these proof give you nothing
for example you put P equal to two point
zero zero why here it will be did with
0:01 instead of some Omega of D or some
anything reasonable so for peace very
closer to this is very bad and so what
is my cause another idea to solve this
usual Michael I I don't know what is
going on to his man but I like me
imagine that you look at this expression
and say okay if the hydrogen direction
is actually much larger than what much
larger than our worst case phone so this
is this point will give me better result
so what if the hydrogen is actually
small remember the only property we need
is a hygienist modes and the deacon he
lives what is large so what happens that
if I look at any ice bigger than what if
if the different lips wide is actually
much larger which means that I go to I X
plus I say instead of X plus a it is
also still inside the Deccan lips wait
so - you can t lips way is much larger
so we are actually going to get
something better so what we are going to
get is the I've express a plus I 5 of X
minus a is bigger you could do some
convex combination of Alpha X and also
the count of an X plus I say so you can
verify this property for our quadratic
function so for a quadratic function it
is automatically true but the decaying
lives right here is it's a soil inside
the different lips where the function is
almost a quadratic function so you can
you can see this week's pressure yes
okay so this is a very simple so you'll
just have this formula and you also have
for any I square such that it's inside
that you can you lips wait you also have
this formula okay
so therefore either you gotta either you
got this one so sorry
so basically this just means that if I
pick the optimal ice so I will pick the
optimal I square such that this is
exactly equal to what so this term
become one where I square there right so
that just means that either you have FX
plus a plus five minus a is bigger or
equal to FX plus four F square or you
will have this linear combination it's a
convex combination so basically you keep
you you still do this expansion now
either you can remove Y and then you
will get a plus one where I square there
or you can have the convex combination
you remove the a here or you plus you
you replace this a bhai say here so
almost finish the proof so the proof
adjusts are very simple so you'll just
start with this guy and then we expand
out to either remove it at zero and then
get some additional term or your you do
this convex combination and then we
expand out what are these two terms so
how do you secure another question of
roses how do you expand out the second
term is you treat it as a function that
has this I say fixed and the other
coordinate are non fix and then this G
is actually a self Concordat function
Tyra function over LP ball of radius
smaller and smaller because you have the
same fix that so this everything here
will sum up to one minus I say to the
power P and so basically by can I see
you can just show that
I thought this guy is bigger or equal to
f of a i0 divided by the same because
this function here is a self component
function for our people of smaller
radius so have this expression and then
this is a proof so we expand out either
this or yeah so basically for general
function so we can prove that lower
bound of this type and now I don't the
question that is Europa is whether this
is omega D or not for a general function
I think his price will remember Michael
by continuing his way that he hasn't
finished and so it's very good if anyone
can continue his pass and just prove
libraries the parameter is actually
Omega D for Ariel people that P is not
equal to 2 okay thanks
[Applause]
okay hi just